[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
December 13th the shelter provided a
roof overhead but also water food and
vitamins this was a relief for April
because they were able to give up these
supplies let's reduce the chance for
violent outbursts and the patrons while
everyone was eating there was a radio
update from the DCD at Sara confirming
that the virus was indeed engineered and
that it was likely a terrorist attack
spread on dollar bills most likely
during Black Friday also the president
is alive and releases a statement on the
radio it's taken several weeks but
finally everyone now knows what they're
up against April we're not to find one
of bills co-workers Mikko he worked with
her at SB GX this was her last option of
where she could go outside of the
various shelters around the city April
only knew where miko lived because of a
party she attended a year or so ago
after a bit of a hike April made it to
Miko's safely this area was considered
to be one of the safer areas of
Manhattan at this time there was a local
gang leader who was protecting the area
and keeping it somewhat safe from the
other hostile factions as an added bonus
mickers place still had power after the
last couple of days I didn't expect
anything good to happen but it did Miko
was there she recognized me and she let
me in they live on the third floor and
still have electricity I'm writing now
by the light of an actual electrical
bulb amazing how quickly that starts to
seem unusual Miko's partner drew is a
nurse he's got some incredible stories
about the first days of the bug neither
of them can believe he's still alive
every so often I was telling his stories
Miko will just reach out and touch him
like she wanted to make sure it was
really there
I wish I could reach out and touch bill
Miko lived with her boyfriend Drew who
was a nurse that survived the initial
outbreak of the virus April our strew to
share everything he knew about the virus
the hospitals were overwhelmed by the
second or third day patients lined the
hallways on makeshift beds and staff
were working in 24 hour shifts the
hospital he was working at was also
losing two to three staff members per
day April spent the next couple of days
scavenging the city only way back to
Miko's April came across several crews
that was starting to barricade a large
area of the city and she was on the
wrong side of the barricade April was in
the middle of what would be soon known
as the dark zone the crews wouldn't let
her leave the area she was beginning to
worry about how she was going to escape
certain checkpoints have been set up
they were only allowing emergency
vehicles to pass through fortunately for
April she managed to find an ambulance
driver who was willing to smuggle her
out for a fee April gave the drive the
last of her money and once they had
passed through the barricades she was
dropped off at 23rd F with the SPG xlab
building is located April hadn't been
back to this area since she watched her
husband being gunned down eventually she
worked up the courage to go inside and
collect some of bills things from his
desk maybe she'd be lucky and find
something that could explain what
happened to him
April found some belongings pictures and
also a comic book card on the comic book
card deals some writing neither snow nor
rain will stop dr. Liu after grabbing
everything she went back to drouin
Miko's house over the next few days
there continued to be riots including
one at the post office where it was
rumored that Sarah had stockpiles of
food and vaccines eventually to disperse
the people teargas and gunfire were used
there are also rumors going around
saying that the virus has killed more
than five million people in the United
States and more than 50 million people
worldwide
Apryl miko and drew kept a fairly low
profile over the next little while
however eventually the supply started to
run low
but drew had a plan the nearby towers
were full of supplies and he proposed
they enter these buildings to look the
goods that they needed April was against
us the books specifically stated to stay
out of high-rise towers they're
essentially death traps if you run into
the wrong people while it was agreed
that it would be risky drew still
convinced Miko and April that this was
needed to be done if they were to
survive despite the warnings of the
Survival Guide drew picked out a
building it was a new high-end luxury
apartment complex that was mostly used
as vacation homes for the wealthy drew
said it should mostly be abandoned and
that they should easily be able to run
through and grab any supplies that were
left behind
you're sure this place is empty
we've scoped it out if we're gonna do
this we need to do it now before someone
else beats us to it in and out before
sunrise just like we planned just like
we planned
the next day they left the apartment
complex at this time April notes down in
the book that Syrah had started pulling
out of New York and that the JTF were
now having to fight off gangs and other
hostile factions when they made it to
the complex they were easily able to
enter without being seen they then began
to work their way up through the
building
looting whatever they could find as they
got higher into the complex the smell of
dead bodies filled the air regardless
they continued to make their way up to
the 29th floor where they ended up
settling for the night they found a room
where they could sleep with their newly
acquired supplies including aspirin
camping gear and boots before they
called it a night they turned on the
radio to see if they could gain any
information on what was happening in the
outside world but before they knew it
they were falling asleep exhausted from
the day's looting however this was a
huge mistake on their part hearing the
noise of the radio men in orange
jumpsuits broke into the room where drew
Miko and April were sleeping and started
firing their weapons drew and Miko were
immediately shot dead but once again
April was left alive they had other
plans for her
after being knocked out April work tied
to a chair straightaway she noticed that
she was in a different apartment April
would find out that the men and orange
jumpsuits were escaped convicts from
Rikers Island
they were rummaging through her
belongings and she was concerned about
what they would do next
suddenly another man entered the room he
looked like he could have been part of
the JTF but there was something
different about him he was wearing
civilian clothes
instead of the usual jtf attire and
seemed strangely calm considering how
nobody was against the ruckus the men
swiftly cleared the apartment of the
ruckus quickly killing them where they
stood unfortunately during the gunfight
he also took several bullets which
caused him to collapse to the ground
shortly after April was still tired in
the chair but you could see that the man
was now lying on the floor conscious but
bleeding out rocking your chair back and
forth until it tipped over she was able
to cut herself free using a knife that
fell during the fight she then crawled
over to him and looked him straight in
the eyes as he was fading away and
thanked him for saving her life the man
that saved her life reminded her of
another person she saw in the back of an
ambulance right and she begins to
suspect that there is a secret society
of vigilante heroes eventually April
figures out that he was a member of the
division because of his backpack the
agent that saved her life was Doug
Sutton he was a member of the noble
squad who was avenging the rest of his
squad that were killed by this group of
ruckus as far as rescuing April he was
merely in the right place at the right
time before she left she grabbed
everything she could which included
Doug's backpack with all of the supplies
rifle and pistol December
25th this day was by far the hardest for
April she spent Christmas Day locked
away mourning the loss of her friends
and husband at this point she was hoping
that this entire thing was just a dream
and there she'll just wake up from this
nightmare December 26th pulling herself
together April gave herself new motive
to continue pushing on through this
disaster to find out why her husband
died April began to further investigate
the book looking for hidden messages in
an attempt to find out what happened she
set out to find this dr. Liu that came
from the comic book card that bill had
written on the reference neither snow
nor rain relates to the united states
postal Creed
so the post-office was April's first
stop to get some answers
dr. Lewis set up in the infirmary at the
post office
when April confronts him he recognizes
her and takes her to a private area the
doctor explains that as far as he knew
they were researching cures to the virus
based off the existing biotech programs
but denies knowing who Billis April is
skeptical and feels that she isn't
getting the full story but he seems her
only way while saying that alliances are
shifting and to trust no one when April
left the post office she came across
another division agent he asked how the
war was going April swears that he could
tell that she wasn't a division agent
this encounter scares her when she
returns home she starts to consider what
she should do with the agent backpack
she doesn't want to be forced into
combat or to be thought of as a thief
before going to sleep
April starts to feel quite unwell she's
fixed that she may have caught the virus
but it's been close to a month since the
outbreak surely at this stage she is
immune but as she finds over the next
few days this isn't the case and after
witnessing her friend Eva slowly die
from it she knows what she's about to
face alone
[Music]
[Music]